I told my entire team to replace
themselves with AI in a week here's the
nine AI tools they came back with across
sales marketing HR training recruiting
and operations let's start with sales
our deal team talks to hundreds of
prospective businesses every single
month now they've implemented two AI
tools to replace themselves first to
increase show up rates for meetings we
now send personalized videos of me using
entirely AI hey Jordan hey Josh Hey
Kevin Hey Michael Nathan Ryan you passed
our initial screen congratulations
huzzah so this saved them all the time
and missed calls and all the time I
would have to spend manually saying hey
Johnny hey Dave I never said any names
now to do that they asked me to record
one video just one the AI would cut in
and replace my mouth and move it in the
right way to say a name that I never
spoke now on top of that the deal team
does a lot of emailing so they wanted to
have a more effective way to write email
follow-ups which normally can take 10 to
20 minutes a pop two hours plus per day
and so they use compose.ai and so here's
an example of what that looks like right
after a call in action now if you think
about the breakdown of how much they
replaced two hours per day on a 40 Hour
Work Week means 25 percent more output
for the same cost that's when for me
it's a win for them because value is
created next my content team came to me
and how they were going to replace
themselves they used three different
tools to get 250 pieces of content out
per week first off they wanted to give
everybody in mosination more ways to
consume my stuff so they added audio
versions of any email or any tweet that
I post that I never actually read these
are actually just me tweeting all day no
one writes my tweets but me you could
actually use the same voice over tool
which was resemble AI to send voice
memos to prospects create entirely
custom text and then send it as a voice
member that you can record in real time
it's freakishly like me and it was only
with about 10 minutes of training 90 of
them come while I drink coffee in the
morning in between sets when I work out
and to give you a quick look into the
future podcast at AI actually scraped
all of Joe Rogan's podcasts to get his
voice down it's entirely possible and
this is a clip from the intro of one of
their podcasts entirely generated by AI
another episode of the Bro jogan
experience on this episode I welcome my
friend who's difficult to describe how's
it going good to see you buddy it's been
a long time since I've been on the show
so in the future audiobooks may just be
recorded entirely through AI because the
author's voice can be duplicated and
they don't have to spend three days
recording the book or every blog post
will have an audio version that everyone
can listen to and the best part is for
me is that the team doesn't have to kind
of disrupt my day hey can you record
this thing for it'll only take 30
seconds that 30 second disruption might
take 30 minutes for me to get back on
track the second tool that they use to
replace themselves is something called
runway.ai This is for image editing and
some other stuff too but we're using it
mostly for images right now so what used
to take 30 minutes to edit out an object
or replace my shirt or change the color
of my hat we can now do in seconds on
the flip side you could also edit out an
entire figure put whatever background
they want behind it on top of that if
you've ever needed to remove background
sound you ever have one of those you're
like where where was this massive fan in
the background in a few clicks you can
remove all of the backgrounds sound of
an audio for any kind of video and they
can do it in seconds the third tool they
used was descript all right this is
pretty slick for a couple reasons number
one is for editing it can get straight
to the point of a video where I say
specific things so if you've ever been
like man I know there's this point in
this video that are recorded that's 38
minutes long rather than mindlessly
clicking play and trying to speed it up
and trying to pay attention while also
trying not to doze off instead of all
that it transcribes the entire video and
you can just pick the part where you say
the thing and it goes straight to it so
rather than trying to find it through
video watching you can find it straight
in the text if they don't have to spend
two hours today looking for different
clips sifting through like pause rewind
pause rewind then they can spend the
rest of that time think about how they
want to package the video what sound or
what music they want to use to evoke an
emotion and that is going to take a
video from a hundred thousand views to a
million views eventually I was gonna be
able to do that too though let's switch
gears to training one of the most
expensive things for any new company is
that they have to onboard new people
after you've already gone through the
process of interviewing tons of
candidates and taking them through first
round second round third round
interviews now you've given them the job
they're in they're still useless because
they don't know how your company Works
they don't know your values they don't
know the Cadence they don't know the
communication structure they don't have
meetings all these things they have to
repeat over and over and over again and
it's time consuming my director of
people came to me and said hey we can
actually create all the onboarding
videos using AI thanks for applying with
acquisition.com my name is Jessica I am
an AI generated member of the
acquisition.com team what's cool about
this is you can have a living document
that you update as things change so
instead of going to a studio setting
everything up and then reshooting an
entirely new video you just change the
text and boom make sure to click that
like button the video changes instantly
if it's not perfect I wouldn't worry
about it because it will be soon if you
speed up AI videos I've noticed that it
sounds a lot more human make sure to
click that like button all trainings can
be just done straight through text and
then the Avatar can deliver them this is
hundreds of hours of human labor that is
just getting eliminated so there are two
things that increase productivity per
worker one is education and the other
one is technology when you have ai based
education you're actually using both the
person who was doing the training is now
using technology to save the time the
person who's receiving the training is
now becoming educated and as a result
becoming more productive now let's shift
gears over to recruiting our recruiters
recruit top talent for our portfolio
companies check out how our recruiters
are using Tavis to create more
personalized Outreach I was talking with
Alex ramosi and they said you should
totally check out acquisition.com if you
only go through using job boards to get
your talent then you're only getting
people who are dissatisfied and want to
leave but the highest producing people
are always employed and so if you want
to have personalized Outreach to get the
best talent consider using stuff like
this then they hop on a candidate
interview after every candid interview
you take notes on the candidate and that
serves two purposes one is if the person
isn't a good fit you send them notes
about why they're not a good fit and you
wish them the best on the flip side if
they are a good fit you want to take
those notes and pass them on to the next
person so they have more context otter
AI solve that by taking notes on these
interviews and timestamps this saves our
recruiters 10 to 15 minutes per call per
day if you can now get more productive
interviews then it means you can get
more productive people into your
business and then the savings on that
are probably incalculable now let's
shift to my operations team so our admin
for internal meetings began using AI to
attend meetings and take notes on her
behalf now instead of having to sit on
meeting after meeting after meeting to
take notes so they could report back to
the executives fireflies AI will take
meetings and they can just look at the
meeting notes in probably a tenth of the
time compared to sitting in on each of
those meetings and then they can
consolidate them they use chat GPT for
that and they can send it to us you can
now have visibility into your entire
organization in a way that you couldn't
ever before now let's talk about the
most expensive resource in every company
time and the number one time waster of
time those awkward like 30 15 minute 45
minute white spaces between meetings and
it's not enough time to do any deep
works you just basically sit there and
waste your time waiting for the next
thing to start that doesn't have to
happen anymore so what our Ops team did
was get the entire team under reclaim AI
to reshuffle calendars in real time to
maximize output of an entire Company by
wait for it 40 rather than have
thousands of emails every single day
simply trying to coordinate times it can
do that by seeing everyone's
transparently and then making it it so
that there are as few blank spaces as
possible on everyone's calendars and the
biggest project that we're using robots
and AI for at acquisition.com is
building our new holdco headquarters we
figure if we use robots we can have them
work around the clock not need to take
time off not have sexual harassment
complaints and we have no fear of them
getting injured okay that one was a joke
but in the not too far future it won't
be